et regardez cette application ce qu'elle
est capable de faire une application
magic est donc vous prenez des photos
sur un stade et là vous passez de chemin
avant la manif y avoir de dégueulasse à
magnifique non les trois jours animale
et de folie à magnifique ans de rallye
ou lazaret ndour a magnifique de gagner
un de leurs maux chez nous on vient sur
cette application
regardez basse et se destine qui est
magnifique à regarder avec l'application
web
sa jambe est inutile ispa non le voleur
n'a pas payé 2,9 euros par an pour une
wii mais si c'est pour mathieu ça c'est
sûr mais ça ou pas maintenant je vais
être à jeun esse jean-michel barrault
joe revient avec ses bars et chez lui le
con il est allé faire papa dans la
regarde je me regarde regarde toi et
regarde avec l'application au [ __ ]
mais pas promettre c'est faux mettez-moi
notre industrie l'artisan à l'ére météo
mais ça va te salue une boulette
ça change pas le changement est ce que
vous êtes capable de me regarder droit
dans les yeux de ne pas écouter ça
chauffe eau d autres choses commencent à
abonder mieux vaut montrer par exemple
parce qu'on a d'autres exemples regardez
l'application c'est pas le mend a agi
avec sagesse
une dernière photo une dernière photo cl
a payé ça suffit pas ces gens vivent
tous cette photo regardez cette
application iphone cette photo en
transpirant qu'est ce que tu as fait un
grand pas que ma mais justement je ne
sais pas pourquoi elle est arrivée chez
eux ils utilisent bien depuis le musée
que je vais vous dire à votre avis qui a
payé 9 euros par an pour utiliser cette
appli agathe à toute action fait partie
mais c'est sûr c'est lui il a payé nos
fonds non mais lui aussi allé au cirad
dossier parce que j'ai les yeux général
un garçon mathieu est un garçon benjamin
benjamin voudrais vous dire déjà je vous
déjà joué à l'âge ou la région rédiger
des bleus attend giro qui est avec nous
oui tu es venu sur le prince qui avait
bien qu'assez m'a tuer enfin voila merci
jonah peu tabou
et l'échec avant se faire vers six ans
la personne on y ait à payer nos soro
pour cette appli c'est quelqu'un que
j'aime énormément à cette personne m'a
pas déçu cette personne mackinder à la
personne m'a surprise oui ou non c'est
pas son genre car cette personne s'est
jamais dire ça c'est bon
la regarde et je l'approuvé sur toutes
ces bateaux nous donnerons alors ça
c'est alors le jul la télévision mais
pas sur scène j'avais pas encore sûr ça
alors s'il vous plaît mais grâce à la
styliste que je joue pas choquant mais
faut rendre l'argent alors génial ce que
vous avez acheté cette appli oui j'ai
acheté oui mais non il appelle gratuit
julien c'est la styliste qui m'a dit
regarde selma montre en photo je vais
j'ai vu ma que j'ai dit je la veux à 9,9
il a payé neuf balles par an enlevez
julien vous n'aviez pas besoin de ça
mais oui la tude don magnifique le nom
la main non là il a mal à ses gosses
aient pris juste une photo il n'a pas
pris la pluie n'est pas des génies et
bien quand c'est une application à vingt
balles par an raymond domenech on a pas
on a que chaque photo c'est là c'est la
photo il a placé la paix qu'il a prises
juste pour se mettre derrière une
fenêtre
bon bah merci ça touche tout blâme et
ben je suis bien les payer 9 balles mais
neuf vols ba ba écoute vous en êtes
contents de l'application va utiliser
une fois donc non est là c'est ouf cette
histoire est bien vous l'achetez pas
vous dingue
une hélice
mais la beauté l'application ne peut que
l'en les dire